effectivement avec une souris avait des
grandes oreillons par le bus pour
l'instant Anthony j'ai une information
parce qu'il faut un peu de culture aussi
tradition culinaire et qui reproduit un
rite lié à la célébration du solstice
d'hiver bravo
ce soir on le présente plus maintenant
Franck très très bon chocolatier
pâtissier basé à Montigny vous êtes
venus avec plein de belles choses tout
simplement sur lesquels
ça c'est sûr alors il y a la
traditionnelle bûche de Noël vos
macarons et puis alors la chose en fait
c'est une cabosse en chocolat c'est à
dire c'est le Cabos c'est le fruit du
cacaoyer et à l'intérieur et normalement
dans la vraie Cabos il y a des fèves de
cacao et nous nous avons mis des bonbons
de chasse à prendre pour la montrer à la
caméra devant vous pour qu'on la voit
bien voilà donc celle-ci se mange
sans chocolat voilà et à l'intérieur
nous avons mis des bonbons de chocolat
de chocolat dedans est-ce que vous
faites plusieurs années le sapin avec
des pieds
exactement
proposer un à votre voisin avec plaisir
mais voilà et après l'autre voisin ovale
on pourra plus parler pour déguster ça
va être compliqué et alors votre verdict
voilà merci c'était important c'est une
émission on teste les choses exactement
ce n'est pas fini et alors votre bûche
de Noël elle est encore encore innovante
cette année bien sûr de quoi est-elle
composée voilà c'est une bûche un nœud
d'Autriche c'est une crème au chocolat
avec un crémeux au géant du genre et un
biscuits
noisette avec des noisettes caramélisées
pour faire le croquant d'accord
oui tous les ans on change à peu près
une ou deux bûches
je peux vous assurer que ça sent très
bon
et alors à la période de Noël c'est
toujours une grosse période pour vous
vous faites une grande partie de votre
chiffre d'affaires annuel voilà c'est
vrai que des fêtes de Noël représente
toujours à peu près 35 à 40 % du de
notre chiffre d'affaires sachant que
pour nous les faits de Noël commencent
le 15 novembre jusqu'au 15 janvier en
fait et alors la bûche c'est un peu
l'attraction parce que c'est la
prévention de du repas de Noël et alors
soit du jour de Noël et vous commencez
en général à quelle période de l'année à
penser à tout ça à imaginer le concept
on commence à penser un petit peu l'été
quand c'est calme au mois de juillet au
mois d'août on cherche un petit peu
j'essaie de trouver tous les desserts
pour toutes les fêtes en planifie et
puis on essaye on goûte on prend des
photos on a changé le nouveau look des
bûches cette année et voilà qu'est-ce
qu'il y a un repas idéal à faire pour
savourer encore plus la bûche après vous
conseillez quoi pour moi l'idéal c'est
le matin pour déguster une bûche mais
bon
les gâteaux c'est les meilleurs gâteaux
sans le matin mais
demain matin dans la rédaction
quel repas pour Noël en tout cas c'est
la question que nous sommes allés vous
poser dans les rues de Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines aujourd'hui
je pense comme d'habitude une dinde avec
du saumon du foie gras des huîtres tout
ce qu'il faut avec 3D 3 entrées trois
plâtres 3 desserts voilà on va bien se
nourrir alors j'en ai absolument aucune
idée parce que je vais faire plusieurs
fois Noël comme beaucoup de monde je
pense c'était pas mis recomposer tout ça
mais il y aura bien une petite dinde à
mon avis qui va traîner peut-être une
petite côte de boeuf je ne sais pas
quelque chose comme ça forcément des
marrons ça c'est enfin nous on est très
classique donc les foires
voilà happy dessert voilà voilà c'est
tout c'est très convivialité voilà c'est
et le repas idéal c'est forcément avec
une bûche même si pour Franck Dobos on
la prend au petit déjeuner exactement
Wilfried et Johanna je vous propose
parce que je vois que là
on va goûter les macarons quand même on
va essayer envoyer
ce sont des bicouleurs c'est une coque
chocolat au chocolat et une coque au
vanille et caramel au beurre salé
soit les amateurs de chocolat
je vous remercie on évitera les gros
plan pendant qu'on les mange mais merci
je préviens si le réalisateur et joueur
ce soir
vous pourriez proposer un autre avec
monsieur
je vous laisse découvrir vos macarons si
vous le souhaitez
oui j'entends dans l'oreillette on me
dit laissez nous en laissez moi oui oui
on vous en laisse nous testons en direct
et nous vous en laisserons en régime
malheureusement on peut pas partager
avec les téléspectateurs donc tout ça
est très bon tout simplement le caramel
au beurre salé
est un peu moins présent enseignant je
les critique maintenant
qui est au chocolat simplement alors que
ils sont fourrés caramel ou beurre salé
et cette idée est venue quand de les
réaliser en fait c'est pour le centre de
chocolat pour se différencier on a fait
les coques bicolore et ça fonctionne
plutôt bien justement quels sont les
résultats sur les produits
on vous les conseille et alors sur cette
période de Noël on parle on en parlait
tout à l'heure avec la crise on va quand
même revenir un petit peu un petit peu
on vous laisse la parole pendant 10
minutes
est-ce qu'il y a une baisse des ventes
mais pas quand on parlait un peu quand
on prépare l'émission on disait oh non
quand il s'agit de chocolat tout va bien
en général quand il s'agit de chocolat
oui les gens aiment bien acheter du
chocolat et comme je disais tout à
l'heure s'il n'y avait pas de chocolat
la vie serait triste dans
oui non mais on n'a pas de baisse de
vente non c'est vrai que donc quand on a
envie de se faire plaisir on vient
chercher les gâteaux
et alors alors votre bûche là pour avoir
un peu près une petite fourchette de
prix quand même parce que c'est très
beau cette bûche
c'est une biche de six personnes et le
coup de 40 euros 50 d'accord très bien
donc voilà pour avoir un bon un bon un
bon dessert le soir du réveillon vous
savez ce qu'il vous reste à faire oui le
prix des Johanna
maintenant
des petites cuillères
pour chacun ça doit être très dur si
vous êtes chez vous et vous nous
regardez ça doit vraiment vous aider
donc forcément
dans la bûche comme ça
mais juste après on est prêt voilà
exactement
merci Pascal Rodier d'être venu aussi
sur le plateau par les solidarités puis
je vous rappelle aussi que l'ensemble de
cette émission toutes les séquences sont
à retrouver sur notre site internet
merci Anthony qui était en train de
manger bravo félicitations je vous
mettrai la main dans le sac et merci à
Valérie une toute dernière information
Valérie Pascal concerne aussi bien le
département des Yvelines que la fin du
monde
cette information il y aura au moins 1
survivant à cette fin du monde yvelinois
Benjamin 30 ans a gagné le concours
organisé par le National Geographic
Channel il pourra être protégé dans la
nuit du 20 au 21 avec tous ses proches
dans un abri antiatomique nous comptons
sur lui
est-ce que vous croyez pour la fin du
monde parce que on en parle beaucoup
certains disent que finalement c'était
une question
par exemple
mais on sait pas trop où donc moi je
vais attendre 12 heures 12 heures
que ça nous fasse 6 heures de plus bon
on en est ça
bon alors en tout cas on espère qu'on va
survivre les magasins pour les magasins
on change complètement de thèmes c'est
le rush en ce moment c'est toute une
logistique il faut mettre en place on va
tout de suite voir un exemple dans un
magasin de Maurepas
les Monster High le jeu chasse fantôme
ou encore l'iPad explorer les grosses
tendances de Noël pour les magasins pas
question de manquer les clients doivent
trouver leur bonheur sans délai novembre
et décembre enregistrent 50% du chiffre
d'affaires annuel pour les magasins de
jouets soit 2 à 3 fois plus de clients
ici à Maurepas les camions
approvisionnent tous les jours et tu de
marché en amont et nouvel agencement
boutique pour plus de visibilité dans ce
magasin de jouets des Clayes-sous-Bois
les rayons ont été réhaussés pour
accueillir plus de stocks entre 5000 et
6000 références en magasin on a été
dévalisé tant mieux mais on
réapprovisionné sur sur certaines
références notamment les Storio 2 donc
les tablettes tactiles ou le jeu de
chasse fantôme qui est le best-seller
sur les fêtes de fin d'année voilà on a
été on a été réassorti donc tout va bien
là c'est la centrale qui gère
les rêves flux marchandises et triplés
durant les fêtes de fin d'année côté
personnel trois personnes
supplémentaires ont été recrutées pour
une durée d'un mois le but aiguiller les
clients le plus efficacement possible et
lorsqu'on cherche un Bakugan j'ai posé
la question
au vendeur et puis ma dirigé vers le
rayon qu'il fallait donc voilà et pour
ceux qui n'ont pas d'idées en fonction
des lettres écrites au Père Noël voyons
on n'a pas le droit de faire autrement